[Music]  my granddad was a soldier in the front  say 41  the boys took his brother  this double up held up the sky was fire  [Music]  millions lost in flames  hate and love are all there no one net  for the same days will sink and sadness  the weight of them - don't lose yourself  to madness  the way  [Music]  New York town worst crumble you're all  New York be still for a moment are just  human at the same old red and the wicked  I'll go once key me the power in the  pain but the heart the lungs the freedom  the fire though tea  des will sink and sadly in the way of  them too tough to lose yourself the  madness the way  [Music]  virus toka comfort  as never are still the enemy is inside  put together  I love this life is so damn fragile leaf  called with every breath and tragic  ignite eats a hole within days will sink  and sadness a weight of them to lose  yourself to madness the way is  [Music]  you  you